una misma estrategia atacar su
adversario en el terreno de la
personalidad le reinicio de la campaña
hacia la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales en Brasil
anuncia una intensificación de las
acusaciones entre los dos candidatos el
viernes el equipo de campaña del
expresidente izquierdista Luis Ignacio
luradas Silva difundió un antiguo video
en el que el actual presidente
ultraderechista Jair bolsonaro afirma
que es capaz de comer carne humana
porque es el quien da una declaración a
un periodista estadounidense y lo repite
Así que no es una invención no son
noticias falsas no es una maldad por
nuestra parte solo estamos informando a
la gente de quienes nuestro oponente
la entrevista que evolucionaron concedió
al New York Times en 2016 donde describe
lo que presenta como un ritual de la
comunidad indígena y ando mami se hizo
viral en las redes sociales el mismo día
una la frecuencia marcó la campaña el
actual presidente que suele referirse a
Lula como ladrona lo califica ahora
también de alcohólico
si pones a un borracho al frente de
Brasil un tipo sin responsabilidades que
tiene un historial de corrupción un
historial de libertinaje hacia la
familia brasileña de ataques a
sacerdotes y pastores de ataques a las
fuerzas armadas de ataques a la policía
crees que funcionará
queda por ver si estas acusaciones
convencerán a los votantes indecisos a
tres semanas de la votación el último
sondeo de datafoliada a Lula como
ganador con un 53% de los votos frente
al 47% de evolucionaron